what are the two items that I can't do
my job without and while I was thinking
that I was doing a fitting with an actor
for a job that I'm doing at the moment
and the only thing I used was my brush
and my comb so I picked the girls in the
office and I couldn't do my job without
them because they keep me sane I came
home one day and said I'd like to be a
makeup artist makeup designer actually I
wanted to turn people into different
characters they're all like oh this job
exists that's terrible you can't make a
living so how to explain to them that
it's not just putting makeup on peoples
may look pretty it's basically I just
want to make people look different and
be different people I would say people
recruitment putting putting people in
places my mum still thought that I was
uni going to get uni and be a doctor or
a lawyer until very very recently yeah
she she'd never understood what I did as
a job and then she went to see King's
Speech and saw my name in the credits
and finally got very kind of yeah yeah
usually something totally different to
anything that I've done before so if I
get some if I get sent something but
even five pages in is similar to
something that I've read it then becomes
a quick a quick
it's skim there's definitely stories and
periods and things I've done before that
I'm not really that drawn to and yeah
like but I always I obviously somehow
got to be known for someone who does a
lot of character to transformation so
there's always some challenging thing ya
do and that definitely does draw me to
being interested in in in the film
interesting characters interesting
stories obviously the dialogue I kind of
just think of it as a story and would I
want to watch
this is my ultimate well it's easy I
think it's easier for me in a sense
because I already am presented with
someone who people believe it's a talent
to portray that bro yeah so so I then I
have the confidence yeah that that
person I can help that person become
what we all want him to add that person
to be to find someone from scratch and
persuade people that that person is the
right person to me seems harder you know
I read lilting and who's just sitting
there thinking oh this would be an awful
thing to cast because you need to
Mandarin speakers and oh you know the
poor person that's getting to end up
casting this which did end up being me
but I really enjoyed the story it's
always finding different offbeat quirky
the unusual the unsuspecting I find that
more interesting just go above and
beyond don't ever settle you know if
you're asked to do something I think a
lot of the reason that I got to I am
today is because if someone asked me for
a I'd give them a plus a hundred and you
know sometimes that wasn't even looked
at nobody really cared but I think there
were certain situations where the things
that I did were kind of off piste and
yeah maybe made me stand out and I think
that's what in the end comes down to is
that complete education yeah to the
projects and to that little bit of extra
that you need to do is sometimes if
something's not working out you need to
just work I don't know how many hours
extra to make it work and that's what it
comes down yeah
[Music]